we apologize to the fans
we apologize to miss Swift
that is the president and CFO of Live
Nation which owns Ticketmaster in the
hot seat today on Capitol Hill blaming a
Cyber attack for The Botch pre-sale of
Taylor Swift's concert tour last year
and also denying Ticketmaster engages in
any anti-competitive practices the Swift
Fiasco was not the first for the company
and critics say it won't be the last if
something is not done now their market
dominance is what critics want broken up
saying fans metaphorically and literally
are paying the price Ryan mathey joins
us live outside Allegiant stadium with
those reactions tonight right
yeah Denise Brian that dominance that
has been growing ever since 2010 with
the merger of Ticketmaster and Live
Nation and at the center of this hearing
is Ticketmaster a monopoly in the live
event space and has it breached
antitrust laws well here in the
entertainment capital of the world
ticketing officials say there's more at
stake here
today we know with certainty that this
merger is vertical integration on
steroids the Ticketmaster Monopoly or
not 27 of the ticket price was the fees
recent study found that for some tickets
it's as high as 75 of Face Value the
nation's largest ticket seller accused
of using its dominance to tack on extra
fees to tickets and partaking in
anti-competitive practice
chaos to purchase Taylor Swift's era
tour tickets this past fall was the
Tipping Point and there was precedence
for this they did the same exact thing
for BTS again zolke says he testified in
front of the Department of Justice
against the 2010 merger now as owner of
Las vegastickets.com he says his
foresight has become reality producers
and promoters seem pretty much
handcuffed into
uh if we're going to use the market
dominant player they're going to
establish the fees and we're going to
have to put up with it these that could
be more than half of a ticket's base
price he estimates up to 70 percent of
Las Vegas venues are on contract with
Ticketmaster making them their primary
seller for years with little control
over what the consumer pays for one
they're capitalizing because Las Vegas
is the entertainment capital of the
world across the country when you
multiply at times all the entertainment
cities and all the venues the dominance
is is glaring foreign
Attorney General's office back in
November said they would be
investigating that Taylor Swift pre-sale
Fiasco when we asked for an interview
today they declined saying they're
unable to comment on ongoing
investigations though they never
provided proof that there is an actual
investigation ongoing reporting live
outside Allegiant Stadium Ryan Matthey a
news now